こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんスマートフォン使ってますでしょ
もうこのご時世スマートフォンインターネット sns とか
ネットワークであらゆる人たちがもつながって誰しもがほぼ利用しているような嫁なら
になってしまったんですけども皆さん忘れてはいけないことがセキュリティとか安全面
だと思うんですよあまりに親しみが良すぎてついつい忘れがち
何けど本当に実は凄い危険であのぜひともそういうセキュリティとかっていうので
しっかり守っていただきたいという僕の思いも込めて今回本当にそういうネット的な中
セキュリティが本年あない公平な1人いいまして統一に so-net の小朝とか
セキュリティのゆるさというのをしっかりしないとどうなるか程度教えるドッキリ
そのほぼとられて大変な
とになってしまうドッキリやっていきたいとおもいます
本当に強いんですよねまずあの今から突起していくんですけども
実際にこういうこと全然ありえると思ってあの皆さん他人事じゃないなと思ってみて
ください
何仕掛けでそいつはですねほんとに緩すぎなんか自分のスマホの中パスワードとか
なんかロックと lan のパスワードがの朴俊なんで知ってそういうので手をせず
ダメだと思うんですよね sns のパサートあったり
あるんですけどそれが僕全部しもうつ入ってる時点でおかしいんですよ
人にを捨てちゃダメそれを急いでる時点でもアウトですから今後てのきょうつけて
ほしいというの人に教えるとコーナーによっていう意味も込めて
ドッキリやっていきたいとおもいます内容を簡単に説明しますと2今から打ちにいくん
ですけども何度だってスマホだけ置いている状況を作り出してあたかもスマホが
逆にドットられてハッキングされてとんでもないことになってしまうっていう長期を
作り出して実際にもいろんな仕掛け茶にしてるでそれを再現していきたいとおもいます
いやい ok
わー
ああああああ
[拍手]
ブーブー
use ブーバーあれ
患者ん
ok さあと呼べる無事にゲットしました
ターゲットのスマートパサード00000で手術よねこれやばくないか
本名セキュリテ題して本当に入ってこちらも多分
0720突破で言うね非常によくないですもう全部行き分で本当に
2数突破画像は全部見られるんですよ
やっぱキッカー
プライベートなボーダーが言わないで僕側しっかりするねから見えられて困るような
やつ欲しい
咽頭を貼っ探していきます
ちょっとまあ色々とデータをもらったりこちらデータをぐったりしてあたかもを救出し
たりスマホがな馬場群チャップって言う
乗っ取られてる感じの子様に帰っていきますのでなんですよエロくねぇ女性バグって
打ったような感じもこの日だけでぱぱっあります
ちょっとしめじと
良いものなくなんですけどもこれを使ってキーボードを打ってる時日本だとアブという
感じ食べてる感じていこうと思います
んあー
不キーボードを使うと思う
[拍手]
はぁ
voodoo こっからいろいろな情報が do do いっ
[音楽]
ブーブー言っは
有葉結構言われてほしいですね
は5台軽でもう撮らせて下さいねなんかなんて時代の方東2線
[音楽]
えーうそがさせるわかんないが強い子になってくれないでしょ
えほんとなやつ寝ヤラーヘッド帰り国どっからですか
そんなホスト役てあっはぁ
ポンチョんだってこんなことしてねー
これ完全なファイマンゼロスようわぁまた明日
エルザどんな術など
芸術してなんかないそれ
はマークは
ふーんじゃあ馬場からが大
を押しましたかああ
ああああああ
飲んでるの
パス付
われ
たマジかよなねっとれいあん
情報漏れてますよ白子川32が続いていた
なぜん
います
はぁっ
んか
あーえーマジか実行バルっていうか知ってガンバレ+ねぇー
女性でした
マジで多いですよえ結句えっ結構笑えないくらい減ってたんですか結構大きく普通に
言えば来てるんですよ
9がこーわーまあ今この3人なんですけどなぁ持ってくれ
またキター
でも使おう親から連絡たの勝ち
ザーンどうやってさん実家バレたからはか
まあ一人暮らししとけばよかった
なかったですけどねここで泉ねー
スバル止めてくるやでーっ
枝に家になる1ちゃーんさあ
代役かつてね
わけです
バッハ
ん
ただ見て家を出てるんですね
土井2手目のやっぱりそれさえ末一人別定を全部でもいろいろ
近くなものできてねたことこんなに食べるたんだよねー
いっ入ったらまだ台を超えてくださいください
皆さんどうぞ部分こちらすんプレオぐらい不可
a子ください本当に一さんちょっと
ねそうだ俺もここにいてもまあ服買う
まずい状況なっちゃったってたらまずいねちょっと元のほど入った
そうな事情報が出ているっていう
[音楽]
うんを倒すかじゃないんだもんね本格止めから
へへっ体て位置情報僕ですか
それで全部出てるかも生きてるって言うのうわぁ姉恋
全く見覚えない館前
うおっん
もし
入ったぜめんですよ
[音楽]
ネットあーテッツでわでわでわまぐむボってなんですけどこ
そう電話派
弱いなぁん
結果つじゃない
フェアワンコ乗っちゃってですよね位置情報であ番号
ライン何回そんなことになっているかなりやばいですよこれ
ちょっと萌えたところじゃないですよ
僕だね
善部町便ぶちょいやもう
で混ぜ止んだりすると本当にと思うんですあをつけたねー
[音楽]
巨人阿部のたテミンの
元が乗っ取られたみたいで
あ昇進を使えそうです
[音楽]
グーッとずっとくる
俺は元カノを元から大
らしい砲弾でこれやばくないですか
これそれやばいのを夜這いするなぜかぶつければっ
パパチームでしょ
イェイやばいやばいよね
位は終わった嬉しいフっていうのが美味しいですまじやばい
のが乾いた
ず性があるから持ってきてくれるとはッッ
ああうんこの開いてい
ph
徹底
わーガー
ないうーんそうそうこそ定めよく思い出せなんでスマホがあんなことになってたと思う
おっ
いやそれをそうなんだけどず放置してると大丈夫なんですよ
なぜかというとパサートかかっているお前は俺に会いにスマホのロックパスなど
安乗センスのパターンと前方せるかこうなっちゃったよそういうこと
ああああああああなのでどんなの仲良い人でもそういうのは教えちゃダメだよって言う
がお得です
影響もありが本当の台でもせず誰では中に人と金ございました
なぜ人でもおじいちゃんですその1から第月だったりしません
まぁこはネット怖っっ恋
入った上で今回のドッキリなんですけどもへとアプリのキーボードアプリ挿絵時に使わ
せていただきました
どんなのかといいますとキーボードで普通に打ちやすいんですけどもキーボードの境界
機能があります
ここでマイク世界を使うとですね自分の持ってる画像とかを使ってキーボードを作る
ことができますちょっと作ってみましょう
これ写真撮りますよ
ん
これこうすると僕まかを使ってキーボードが作れるというわけでございます
こういう感じですねそっとがこれです
bar した時もの感染という感じでオリジナルのキーボードを作ることができます
写真だけじゃなくて動画もできるよという高齢で売ってる人のコーデッ
はいこうすることによってこうすることによってこうやって動く
キーボードを作ることが出来ますこれすごいですよそしてスタンプ長編各機能があるん
ですけどもこれすごいですよ
ここで面白いって打つと面白い画像トップの自動的に出てきますはいこれで外れシャ
[ __ ]って言うと僕の画像がこういう感じで出てきます
すごく便利ですそして中
自作エフェクト機能というものがございます自分でエフェクトを作ることができますか
店に行ってみましょう
こうあのドッキリでも使ったんですけどもエラーとかコーションとか出るとめっちゃ
怖いんで
でこれ今誰を押すとコーションが出てたんを押すとエラーでという状態でございます
これで例えばですよさあ押すとコーション
ターンとエア出てくるという風に自分でメイクすることができ
ますさらにこの作ったりベッド友達でも共有できるんでぜひ一つと一緒に楽しんでみて
ください
あのキーボードを持つと希望となると思うんですこのカチカチカチっていうこれも自分
でできるんですよ
とび企業ということ設定できるんですけども
企業が作れますとってここで好きな音を6本できます
はいそれで録音可能です
はいこれで例えば
[音楽]
うって確定をストー
という元米ですねあのず部であのいいほど夫を設定することもできます
人気富山しめじのキーボードを使えば様々なオリジナルなものができるのでぜひみな
さん楽しんで作ってみてくださいどっきゅんにも使えますよ
清水なダウンロードは動画の概要欄からできますぜひダウンロードしてみてください
あと俺のオリジナルきせかえもあるんで是非使ってみてください
ザーンちゃんとパスワードをかけとけよ
ああ
[音楽]
me
re だった